over the past twenty four years this
plane is flown enough to circle the
world
twelve hundred times
now it's arrived at a desert tarmac in
Goodyear Arizona
this is the home of arrow turbine a
company that specializes in all things
aircraft
preppy Roger Hodges is the maintenance
manager usually he repairs aircraft but
this one is different for one good
reason it's worth more dead than alive
this 747 is now beyond repair it's old
and too expensive to maintain but rather
than trash it Roger will make sure it's
carefully pulled apart piece by piece
just like cars or anything else aren't
gonna last forever
there's still many parts within the
airframe and engines that are work sent
in to overhaul 30% of this airplane will
be utilized in future Senhor settings
the Jumbos parts are so interchangeable
because the plane's basic design has
changed little since its first
commercial flight in 1970
back then it took several hundred people
and four months to make a plane
now just a handful of mechanics will
attempt to tear one apart in only 12
weeks
among them Derek Pfeiffer he runs the
crew from the ground we'll get an air
with a ratchet wild Bonebrake is in
charge of snakes on this plane
well Pete Faulkner will try to dodge
them good all are experts in their own
right
only one problem none of them have ever
pulled apart an aircraft this big
this is a first point 747 is the biggest
aircraft we have to tear down so far
already
it's by far maybe the biggest challenge
it's just huge we don't want to damage
it we don't want to get hurt
everything they do would be a learning
experience they must rely heavily on the
manuals that were used to build this
plane more than two decades ago
big parts everything's like four to five
times heavier and we're accustomed to
takes tooling takes lengths to be able
to handle that kind of way
it'll be a four step process first
workers must gently remove the engines
for elephant-sized jets to be handled
like eggs second they must remove an
inventory any resellable item from
piping to coffee makers Paul can return
to service on other aircraft
third they must extract hazardous
material like depleted uranium and take
it to a safe location
workers will also strip and trash
anything else of little value like worn
seat covers and insulation
finally they must crush the remaining
metal so it can be melted into solid
bars of aluminum
and from there made into other objects
like electronics hardware even furniture
the aim is to recycle an incredible 98
percent of the aircraft and reclaimed
spare parts and scrap worth about 6.8
million dollars